التحديد الاستراتيجي
ات المتحده الامريكيه وحلم على الاطلسي
على روسيا وهم في مواجهه واستمرار في
عمليات التسلح لاسيما في اوكرانيا وهذا
يهدف الى تاجيل اسراء اكثر فاكثر في هذه
المنطقه من العالم وهذا قد يؤدي ايضا الى
صدام مباشر هناك مخاوف فعليه من هذا صدام
المباشر ما بين روسيا وحلف الناتو بشكل
عام حتى كذلك عن مخاطر المواجهه النوويه
وكذلك عن
البيولوجي الذي ان الولايه المتحده
الامريكيه عمدت بتطويره في اوكرانيا خلال
سنوات الماضيه وهو مصدر قلق وخوف بالنسبه
لروسيا حاليا تحدث ايضا عن القرار الذي
اتخذته روسيا بتعليق العمل باتفاقيه
ستارتو وهو قرار نتج عن تسلسل من الاداء
الاعدائي من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اتجاه روسيا وكذلك قال ان لا مج
ال حاليا
للحوار المباشر بسبب التعامل الامريكي
بشكل خاص مع روسيا وقطع اي فرصه لحوار
قريب شكرا لك يا دينا كنتي معنا مباشره من
جنيف